into this towards the end but let me
briefly describe
what will be covered in the genomics
program and then i will go back to
describing what the project oriented
component really is
so for the genomics program which is an
intermediate program
we will cover
the basics of genomics the applications
of
genomic sequencing data analysis to
study a variety of different examples
like germline mutations genetic diseases
cancer
and
similar things to that
so uh briefly to describe what i will do
today is i will cover some of those
basic things provide you with some
examples and then at the end i will go
back to this idea of project oriented
training that you can learn
in these programs that are going to be
coming up
so as you all know
dna especially the human dna is very
complex and it's organized in such a way
that we can
understand some of it but really we need
to have all the information about the
genome to be able to ask questions about
the dna not only that also the dna
itself is stored in a very compact way
and so to understand what information it
contains we need to understand the
organization of the dna which is
organized by chromosomes and so the
chromosomes are essentially these
strings of dna that are um
attached to histones and uh when we
think of dna right the first thing that
we need to think about is what are the
actual elements that matter right where
should we look at and so where we need
to look at is typically referred to as
the whole exo right so what are those
specific regions of dna that produce
protein
genes so what we'll do in this program
is we will talk about cole exome
sequencing that helps us understand how
the genotype or what's written in the
dna defines the phenotype the phenotype
of an individual cell the phenotype of a
tissue of an organ or the whole organism
now it turns out that only one percent
of the human genome about one to two
percent of the human genome are
protein-coding genes
and that number has significantly went
down from the original expectations that
researchers had when they were starting
to sequence the human genome
so today we have about 22 500 genes but
that number varies across different
research fields and so really we're
going to look specifically at that known
part of the genome which we call uh the
exome right the the part of the genome
that is being expressed
one of the basic applications of
genomics is to identify bugs in the code
how can we link specific variants or
differences from the reference that
allow us to make assumptions that the
sequence change results in a particular
uh change in phenotype for example here
you can see how a mutation could change
the cell phenotype which in this case is
the red blood cell uh to be the sickle
cell right so that sickle cell disease
is defined by one such change
what we will also look is how we can
start characterizing these mutations and
start understanding their functionality
how individual nucleotides form
trinucleotide codons and how changes in
specific positions in these tricodons
result in the change at the amino acid
level we will talk about different types
of point mutations like substitutions
insertions and deletions and we will
discuss what are genetic variants versus
mutations versus
neutral mutations pathogenic mutations
and essentially mutations that don't
matter
and the way that we will talk about this
is we will try to understand the changes
at the sequence level at the dna
nucleotide level
we will then try to understand what are
some of the thresholds that are used to
understand whether the mutations is the
mutation is a coding or a non-coding
mutation
where that mutation is found is it found
inside the gene at the promoter of the
gene at the splice junction of the gene
or whether it is silent and we will also
look at the impact of the non-coding
mutations and whether these non-encoding
mutations matter at all we will also
take a look at some examples of where
such germline mutations are known to
play a difference in phenotype and how
they affect the phenotype
so when we talk about these types of
mutations we will also apply those two
somatic mutations as well as germline
mutations and we'll talk about how to
find them and what type of sequencing is
required to be able to find them in a
with a level of confidence that you can
actually annotate them and interpret
them
so genomic variation that we will
discuss
will include look looking at individual
single point mutations
as well as structural rearrangements and
copy number variation as well and as i
already mentioned we will take a look at
how we can observe the impact of these
mutations
in in the sense of affecting a phenotype
and that could be either a disease or
that could be just a difference in
condition
we will also take a look at the
relationship between the specific known
genes that can that typically
have these mutations at different levels
at the level of where they are found in
the chromosome what does the gene look
like in terms of what's being expressed
and what's the variation of expression
at the 3d structure of the protein that
that gene codes for and also at how
people validate that these mutations
actually cause the phenotype or a change
in function
now to understand all of this at the
practical bioinformatics level we will
also discuss how this data is generated
so we'll take a look at different types
of
sequences sequencers
and different methods of sequencing
including targeted sequencing amplicon
sequencing and whole dna sequencing that
is applied for genomics and to really
understand the process we'll take a look
at how the sequencing machine works and
what type of data does it produce
and when we come to that part of the
data we will actually look at what do
these files look like and so we'll try
to understand what is the information
that is encoded in this dna sequencing
data and then how can we analyze this
data which we will start from by
learning the logic of analysis so really
how can we
perform
alignment how can we find variance how
can we interpret the variance
structurally and how we can measure
relationships between sequences and
changes in sequences
so here are some of the applications
that we will look at we will look at
the need to clean or pre-process our
data
we'll talk about the need for calling a
variant determining whether this is a
mutation and annotation how do we
actually know what this mutation could
be related to
but we will also look at additional
applications of different methods where
we can either visualize the data that we
have or identify a particular type of
mutations like germline or somatic
mutations
we'll learn to work with genome-wide
dissociation studies where we need to
understand the relationship in a
population to a phenotype
and what is needed to make that kind of
an association
and we will also take a look at
downstream interpretation of the found
mutations so how can we actually know
what a particular individual mutation or
multiple mutations what do they mean and
how can we identify other factors
associated with that and so here as an
example we will use a study that shows
how we have individual or monogenic
snips and how we can look at polygenic
snips where monogenic are strong
associations that are typically
rare but they are
commonly associated with the phenotype
or polygenic scores that are more
complex and how do we actually analyze
the data to try and determine what is
associated with what and this is
typically referred to germline mutation
so some of the things that you will
learn in this part of this course is you
will look at how to load the data how to
process the data how to find meaningful
associations and also how to provide a
report on what you have found using both
the tbi info platform and coding in r
now beyond those we will also look at
some of the applications of genomic
sequencing for biomedical research and
there we will look at examples for drug
metabolism somatic mutations inherited
mutations rare genetic disease as well
as drug resistance in bacteria which is
going to be a little bit different but
with similar principles
as the part of that you will learn what
goes on behind those typical
reports that are provided to cancer
patients for example and how do these
studies that intend to understand the
mechanistic or statistically significant
mutations how do they use this research
to actually produce such results
also we will look at how cancer occurs
and we will use some examples the
commonly known and and something that
everybody has probably heard about like
p53 as well as less known as
and maybe less understood
individual mutations or
multiple mutations that have high
association with a specific phenotype so
we'll talk about point mutations
insertions deletions and rearrangements
like copy number variations
so i also mentioned that other
applications of
sequencing might include finding
specific mutations responsible for
drug resistance like antibiotic
resistance and tuberculosis or
association between
variants identified in short sequences
for example we'll take some examples of
viral sequencing data to try and find
specific mutations that have been
associated with the phenotype
as a part of this training you will get
access to our online coding
which is like an element that you can
find inside the coursework where you can
practice how to
write code with a lot of guidance right
so one of the important parts of this
program is to provide you with the logic
of analysis and then introduce you to
practical skills that you can also take
with you and continue to learn on your
own
so when we will do that we will this is
just an example of an exercise where we
will take several dna sequences from
patients compare them to the wild type
and try to determine what should be the
specific
diagnosis based on this information that
we should give to a patient so again
some practical examples of how you can
use this type of
data and this type of analysis to
identify some important information for
biomedical research
so in summary we will provide you in
this genomic program omixologic genomics
program
variety of examples and opportunities to
try to analyze whole exome sequencing
data
from humans and non-humans alike we will
introduce you to how this type of
analysis could be applied in basic and
translational research you will
understand the terminology and the
commonly used approaches for analysis
and will be able to perform those
independently as well
using the platform for logical and
user-friendly analysis as well as
learning how to take the process data
and extract from their meaningful
insights using some coding skills not a
lot but at least some in r
and we will also show you how to deal
with a variety of different
data types that you will be expected to
work with as you are introduced to
genomic data analysis
so to briefly summarize
the two programs that we discussed today
are introduction to bioinformatics
getting started with big data
bioinformatics
and genomics
now i think tomorrow we're planning to
do another orientation session that is
going to be dedicated to meta genomics
and data science which are more advanced
programs for those that already have
some basics in those fields like you may
might have some
background in microbiology or maybe you
are interested in data science which
will typically require you to have some
background with coding so you must have
at least a little bit of experience
coding in r or python because very
quickly programs will become
challenging for those that do not have
that background
so again how do you register for these
programs if you are interested
this is the page for introduction to
bioinformatics so again i put in the
link
in the chat for introduction to
bioinformatics and this is a page for
the genomics program
so the genomics program
sorry
the genomics
program
right here
these are the topics and the syllabus so
you will find here all of the specific
details
all of these programs are going to last
for three months so for the whole
semester
um the introduction to bioinformatics is
much
shorter in terms of what we typically
expect people to spend on that program
but you can take up to three months to
complete it
genomics and data metagenomics and data
science might require a little bit more
time
the process will be that you will have
all of the materials
for example this is a course on this
portal that you registered for already
on the omics learn portal
so here you will find some asynchronous
materials and every week you will have
an email with a video lecture that
connects these materials into a program
in addition to that you will have access
to our mentors so if you have any
questions along the way you're
struggling with some piece of code
you're trying to build a pipeline and
it's not working or you have a
conceptual question you would like to
understand some topic that you don't
think was explained well enough we will
have
two q and a sessions per month that you
can join to ask all of those questions
now for hana is going to be the course
coordinator she's going to be available
for collecting those questions and
making sure that we have those questions
ready for whenever we have the q a
session and she will be able to point
you in the right direction for
registering for those q a sessions
what does a program actually look like
just uh
here
so a program
will have for example let's go to this
genomics program
so this program as you can see will have
uh once you're registered um you will
see here the full curriculum
and you will be able to see here the
video recordings that are sent to you as
well and complete those
and once you are signed up you will find
on your profile
that right here you will find whatever
program that you're a part of you will
find that mentioned right there for
example here this is a program that
already finished and once you have
finished you will find your certificate
of completion right here and also you
will be sent a pdf version of that
program at the end as well
so now for those of you that are from
lbrn
lsu or nepe
maybe for hana you can take a little bit
more time to just go over the process
again